but
it's acid
but by looking at the phone
even though I've seen it you can know
that this person must have a knowledge
why why I must have a knowledge because
this phone
a quiet someone with knowledge to create
it yeah this person must have a power
ability
to start looking at the phone but this
is impossible for me and one of us here
just by looking at the phone we can say
about the creator of the phone he must
become a student
but it doesn't understand our
honest knowledge
the surrounding world and there must be
some of the phrases
no before I'm gonna say that the
question I'm gonna ask you this creation
is a product of knowledge or knowledge
all of us
and we can based upon knowledge or
knowledge blind matter
the ultimate I say
initially
is
three days
of weather
now before we go with knowledge for
example the concept I do agree the
initial I believe there is some
spiritual force or God or a Creator
exactly yeah so we must have a career
that's my point it's been
illusion
the days of book was written by a
physicist called Pizza uh
Atkins it's Atkins yeah he's a physicist
yeah you know a book called seven news
yes
something to do with it that's seven
heaven it's seven days there's more to
do with this right and that's so the
idea isn't necessary to be swayed to one
relation but there's an understanding
fall fetch to say that each individual
religion wouldn't have that through path
jointed together basically when you look
at Islam and she died in Christianity I
can agree with it yeah yeah but when it
comes to Buddhism like maybe maybe date
of something from the previous promise
messages but Buddhism first thing we
cannot check it back because we don't
even know if we would exist or not we
don't have historical truth yeah and
even the teaching when Buddha starts
teaching and so on and even they they
believe they have and so on but how
would you go step by step yeah okay so
first you want to create now with the
Creator that uh the point I'm gonna
mention is
you're talking about how the universe is
connected everything is connected yeah
but
the reverse argument that would be the
natural selection stuff
remember there's an answer for
everything but I'm gonna analyze it it's
just that okay so so the point here is
that there's the eyebrows and there's a
perfect damage yes because of the sweats
yeah you have teeth in your mouth
why is that why every human being has
seen his mouth
and everything is random that's a
breakdown son
you're hungry right is the whole
Evolution thing so that Evolution some
animals have
certain adaptive Natures
of entity yeah I understand Evolution I
agree yeah
so what do you have to understand yeah
you know a lady last week yeah she's
saying because we know the reasons so I
don't think we should live in the
Creator because you know why this work
why this doesn't work what is happening
I said no that's not true because right
we can go to traffic lights
traffic light is working without no one
touching it
because but that doesn't mean no one
could have made it
so doesn't mean because we know okay the
reason it went red for such and such the
reason went green light was such that
that doesn't necessitate there's no
Creator I think it's the biggest problem
the biggest problem I have with
there's all these brilliant things right
that has been created
terrible things because I don't know
like certain diseases yeah and you know
yeah that's my point my point this is
this is where like at least personally
I've struggle to be like I want to
believe there's a Creator but if there's
a Creator then why would he create such
terrible things
you mentioned already
by the Creator okay so so that's why
many people don't understand why there
is diseases when there's sickness why
there is evil and stuff
to create a place which is only evil
that they have fire and they create this
place which is mixed evil and good and
he put us here with a free will for you
to choose if you want to feel good that
will lead you to the good place if you
want to follow evil that will lead to
evil please understand so I'm going to
test you I understand understand final
question man is there anything
Christianity
right he provides that kind of bridge
like let's say I'm a simple personal
what's to say that I'm still able to get
into I don't believe that I don't
believe you guys
should die for nonsense
let's say I'm
writing on the wall for me you know what
I mean what do you mean by that in terms
of life
does that means
I don't that's it no no no no because I
know the reason why I like the idea
not sin more but I can try this stuff
right you know and what we have is a
verse Allah said Arabic translator yeah
said to my four servants
transgress and get themselves not just
commit sin there won't be your
boundaries of sins
Allah forgive all the sins
growing and aggressive
yeah
but you know what is it Allah every
chapter is
the most merciful the one who's full of
mercy and what's the one chapter
is
because that chapter is speaks more
about war
is politicism and disbelief
yes disbelief and politicism is one of
the worst thing why because this belief
and praying to other than God becomes
under believing God why is that you said
all the creators Almighty you are the
greatest you are the almighty but I
believe you should you don't deserve the
attributes only for you I'm gonna give
it to create that comes and the ability
my intentions would never be to the
middle
I understand that that's why it's
technically speaking if you don't know
then for example if someone is a
politician I'm not a blind face
but there's two things you cannot by
some reason but even that islamically
there's a best in the Quran Allah said
Allah will never punish people until the
knowledge reached them for example
someone is a politist a Christian and a
Diet because you believe the truth of
Jesus they will enter Paradise before
Prophet Muhammad came likewise the true
flaws of Moses before Jesus came they'll
enter Paradise yes so not if someone
does not believe in Islamic teaching
because followers
yeah it's better if it dies
because why the knowledge of the breath
Islam never came to him even though as
follower came and tell him
from Justice
to create
it's on sale yeah that kid's creation
and we can see even the wisdom of the
Creator and let me come back to evil
yeah you know there is a story in the
Quran
breaks down because we don't believe
evil comes from God we believe evil is
uh subjective from our own perspective
is evil but not from God yeah
and there's a story and breaks it down
deep and thank you for giving me your
time yeah sorry I don't wanna you know
so listen to this story
so there's there was a prophet Moses
yeah he said his phone was asking he
said almost is there anyone here
knows more than you he said no no one
knows so Allah rebuked him he said all
Moses why did not say Allah Knows Best
so that Allah knows there's someone who
has more knowledge than you about
certain things and his name is
go and meet him in such place so you
want to meet him to learn from him yeah
so they were traveling together that's
across the river
they were utilizing it to cross people
from one side the other side and they
charge them so they helped moose up
Moses and his friends but I didn't
charge them they said you know because
we know we are righteous man so go for
him who is about to leave he got a knife
and he scratched the boat
so Moses he was surprised
young boys are poor and they were they
helped us really and they attract other
people they said they see most I've told
you you're not going to be patient with
me
who is he doing
the young boy again then they traveled
again they carry on traveling they went
to the village and there are other
people to host them
people rejected
so there were two young men dad the
house and their house about to collapse
the world
went and fixed it for them for free
the young boys who helped us you go to
Christ therefore these two young men who
asked them to host us they reject us and
you go help them for free that doesn't
make any sense he said no he's gonna I'm
gonna tell you why I did this
so what happened the young boy they were
in a village they had a king this King
he would take any boat that is in a good
condition so Moon I will scratch it in
order for the
to keep
salt and to provide the research in
their family
it's good because we didn't have the
knowledge
the knowledge of the outcome you know
win 14 things in his Universe we human
beings we don't know what is the outcome
of it we just look at it from the the
the first score in the stand let me
personally I want prison you understand
I always have drugs when I'm in prison
and there was certain drugs I couldn't
stop taking it was very bad for me
why this happened to me why Allah
and they come up and that will not
understand
drugs I changed my life I started
working but when it happened to me
straight away because I didn't know the
outcome of it
was everything that makes the things
that's it that's what they say they say
how many negative things Within These
positive things in the stand but because
Allah has a lot of the has seen the
outcome original house right that's it
we too quick to jump yeah we understand
Folks up I'll give you another example
imagine all of us here standing up close
the road there is someone
cutting off someone's foreign
so the point here is that this argument
of evil it was used by a Greek
philosopher to reject God and as a
Christian what it was used as a
Christian because the Christian
encouraging they say God loves everyone
and everything but if you say that I
agree how he said tell people that
everyone and God's Gonna punish someone
forever in the Hellfire that doesn't
make any sense instead we are the most
demonstrate Allah loves but not everyone
but Allah Allah have mercy on everyone
but only likewise Allah doesn't only
have the attributes of love as the
attributes of Mercy attributes of Mighty
for example and Justice church maybe the
judge will give a capital punishment a
murderer but that doesn't mean the judge
is evil man what it means the judge is
wise and it's just
in your own room and there's a fire
everywhere
and you try your best to serve yourself
if you know what you try your best and
you wouldn't you gave up before it's
over and that came and save your life
what would you say to me thank you would
you remember me all the time
that reminds you yes
you will remember me all the time saving
your life
so what we're not grateful and remember
to give us the life for free
it's that wow thank you now sometimes I
mean you guys it will be very nice this
is the step you know we're talking about
believing God yeah if you want to buy a
gift to her are you gonna buy a gift
that your love or she loves
like what if you want to watch the
Creator you should Worship in the way he
loves not the way we love so we
shouldn't know what he wants to us
understand so that's why we believe he
said Moses Jesus and Abraham you know
what Jacob the last of them now
Prophet Muhammad said and we can see it
right now he said you will come outside
with interest you're not interested yeah
it'll become widespread even if you are
not involved directly would affect you
yeah has he been the last prophet still
yes the last book is right where is the
last proper time so when you look to the
history of the foreign
because that Prophet who came before him
his registration was only for a specific
time so God send another legislation yes
the other one because the prophets the
other reason for God sent another
Prophet The Prophet who came before his
teaching would not preserve who's
corrupted so God will send another
Prophet to correct the teacher so it
doesn't feel like we're overdue anyone
now no because we don't need that it's
not right because the prophet Muhammad's
teaching is being preserved and it's
perfect
about the the interest now to open a
bank account even if you are not
involved directly with interest will
affect you your money's been used of
course you ask yourself how a man that
exists in 1400 years ago
is known about something randomly
detailed specifically and there's many
but I'll give you because I I know you
have to go guys and I'm going to give
you a book to read please all right
thank you very much
for you
I'm sorry
foreign